صباح الانوار جميعا اعزائي كل مشاهدي
برنامج صباح العربيه اولا تحيه الى البلاد
التي احبها جدا الى اصدقائي اللبنانيين
تحيه الى لبنان هذا جبن الحليمي احد
منتجات سامي الفرياني هنا في تونس يصنع
الجبن الحلم اللبناني وعديد الاجبان
الاخرى اردت فقط تحيه صغيره الى لبنان
الجميل واصدقائي اللبنانيين قبل ان ندخل
في صلب الموضوع
وترك ذلك العالم الفاخر الجميل ليتجها الى
عالم الهوايه هوايته هي احياء التراث
التونسي وتجديده من خلال الاعتماد على
وصفات الاولى لجبنت ستور والاجبان
التونسيه ودمجه وصفات اجنبيه وكذلك
التاسيس لاجبان تونسيه صرفه على غرار جبن
الرمان
واجبان اخرى
بتتابع معروفه على الصعيد الدولي بالتعاون
مع همم حرفاء او عفوا مونتجين ايطاليين
وفرنسيين وروسين وما الى ذلك معي مباشره
سامي هنا نحن في مقر الابداع ومقر اللذه
والاجبان الطيبه هنا في الحمامات ذكينج
سامي
اليوم صباح الانوار سامي اليوم الانتقال
ميناء الانتقال من الهوايه الى
الممارسه ممارسه هذه المهنه وتحويلها الى
مورد رزق وكذلك موطن شغل ترك سياحه وتحول
الى عشق الاجبان كيف تقيم هذه التجربه همم
العالم السياحه الى عالم الاشبال وهي
الطريقه يعني تقليديه انا دخلت في الدومين
وتركت المجال السياحي
من بين الحاجات التي تطميرها اللي هي
الخروج
همم بعد هذه ال- ال- ربما التمشي او هذه
الفتره هل تعتبر انك وجدت صعوبه في جعل
الهوايه مورد رزق
لكن للانتقال درجه درجه لان نصل المبتغنى
معناها التحويل من الجبنه البيباني
اجنبيه بلمسه تونسيه سامي لو تعرفنا اولا
على الاجبان القائمه على الوصفات التونسيه
ما هي بالضبط هنا امامنا
همم
[موسيقى]
التونسيه ايها
التونسيه
كذلك واجبنا الرمان
الرمان واحنا دخلنا يعني ال- اا صناعه
الاجبان بالرمان وهو يعني الوحيد اللي
موجود في العالم والجبنه اللي بالفحم
الطبيعي كذلك الجبنه المدخنه الجبنه
المدخنه والجبنه بالفحم الطبيعي
وتخصصنا في صناعه البوراتا في صناعه
الجوده وهي التونسيه
100%
باعتبار ان تونس احد اشهر منتجيه الرمان
في العالم وكذلك سامي الفرياني من مكان
معروف جدا بانتاج الرمان فتم الاعتماد على
مكون الرمان من اجل الانتاج جبل الرمان
لاول مره وهو على فكره جبن لذيذ واا لذيذ
جدا سامي اليوم لدينا ازمه في تونسيه ازمه
الحليب لنحيط المشاهدين بهذه المساله
اليوم وصلني الاجبان ربما تعتدهم اشكال
كبير من حيث التزويد بالحليب
والجوده بالضبط